hi my name is keane brown i'm head of
product for project banzai project
banzai is a new service from microsoft
that enables engineers subject matter
experts
and others who are interested to teach
an ai to solve complex
dynamic control problems at its heart
this new technology uses something
called machine teaching
machine teaching is a new way to express
what it is you want an ai to learn
and how you want to learn it one of the
core components
in this new technology is a reliance on
simulation
with simulation the ai can learn from
lots and lots of data before we go and
put it onto a real system
steve is with me today from mathworks as
part of the bonsai service we spent time
working with mathworks to integrate
simulink i'd like to introduce steve and
have him tell us about simulink
and how to use that to build a
simulation
for a for a physical system hi my name
is steve miller
and i'm the product manager for simscape
i work at the mathworks office in munich
germany
and i help engineers model mechanical
electrical fluid
and other physical systems using
simscape i'm here to help keen create a
simulation model
so he can create an intelligent control
algorithm today we're going to learn
about project moab and how to build a
control system using the bonsai service
that can interact with moab in the
context of the simulink simulation
we have a goal of helping engineers
develop ai systems
using their own domain expertise and
knowledge
having a model of the physical system in
this case moab
will make generating the training data
for the ai algorithm
much easier instead of working with just
one system on a desk
you can use many virtual copies of the
moab system
the moab is a mechanism that has a plate
that can be tilted
and the tilt angle of the plate is
controlled by three mechanical linkages
beneath it with simscape it's really
easy
all you have to do is import the cad
model all of the kinematic relationships
the parameters that affect the dynamics
are all integrated automatically into
the model that you see here
the intelligent control system that
keen's going to develop goes in here
it's going to figure out what the tilt
angles are for the plate
if you look in the animation you can see
we don't have a very good control system
yet
now those tilt plate angles are not what
the mechanism needs
we need the motor angles for those
linkages
this inverse kinematics control
algorithm will convert those tilt angles
to the motor angles
those motor angles are what's going to
drive the mechanical model of moab
in this subsystem you can see the
simscape model you can see the ball
the plate the motors and the base
if we look in the animation you can see
the linkages that are tilting the plate
it looks just like the real system so if
i needed to modify it i would know
exactly what to do
we also had to model the contact between
the ball and the plate
we have to characterize this behavior
very accurately
if we generate our training data with an
inaccurate model
the resulting ai algorithm won't work in
the real world
to get an accurate model is why we're
using simscape
in the real system a camera is going to
record the position of the ball
in the simulation model we can measure
the position exactly
these measurements are what we're going
to use to generate the training data
so to use bonsai with a technology like
simulink there are three overall steps
you go through first is to integrate the
simulation with the service
second is to train an ai to control of
the device that's
modeled in the simulation third of
course is the ability to export the
brain and
either use it with the device or the
simulation and wherever it's needed
today i have a simulink model in this
model you can see that i have a block
that is a controller for controlling the
device inside the simulation
i can connect that simulation to the
bonsai service then with the bonsai
service i can use techniques like
goals concepts in order to teach the
kind of control system
that i need to solve my problem the
first step
is to run the seamless simulated model
you can see this here
then i have once i'm satisfied that my
model is working
properly in its integration with the
bonsai service i have the ability to zip
it up
upload it and then use that
to scale training for uh
and accelerate ai development you can
see here i have some code
some some what we call inkling code that
describes
how you want to teach the ai to control
the service when i have this code i can
click the train button
after that we generate an ai and train
in coordination with simulink
to create a control system that is
exposed to the dynamics of the ball
moving on the plate
we encourage you to try out the bonsai
service itself
you can find it as an azure service at
azure.com
we also have a lot of publicly available
documentation
we encourage you to visit
docs.microsoft.com search for bonsai and
look at the information we have
available there
thanks for joining us today and seeing
as we use bonsai and simulink to create
an intelligent control system